clark county still on track to wrap up  its vote count by tomorrow evening  today registrara voters joe gloria  reported 549 ballots were taken in  yesterday  staff expect another small batch in  today as well gloria also says  he does not anticipate any problems with  the final provisional numbers  it has been a very stressful election  and my staff has done a tremendous job  of hanging on and as i mentioned the  other day they did seem to get a pep in  their step  because they knew we were close to the  end the final ballot counts expected to  be submitted by five o'clock tomorrow  night if a recount is required the  department says it is ready